the River Stour wines serenely through
historic Canterbury far from the
political storms of Westminster punters
glide on crystal-clear water
braving September showers it's a far
from typical constituency but a crucial
battleground
you've got the students who are on the
whole very very liberal usually on the
on the left or centre then but you've
also got a fairly affluent section of
Canterbury who in my experience can be
quite aggressively conservative tourism
is big business here more than seven
million visitors a year generating five
hundred and fifty million dollars brexit
uncertainty has a direct impact we
actually had a number of number of
school groups from from Europe cancel
because they were concerned about some
chaos and delays of Calais and they're
worried about having their kids stuck in
traffic for hours and hours and hours in
2017 the city's 40,000 strong student
body helped return a Labour MP here a
shock result in a strongly conservative
region with the next election date still
uncertain only the Conservative Party is
so far named its candidate and she's
already knocking on doors stockpiling
campaign materials and mobilizing
supporters I want a general election I
want to get the people of Canterbury the
chance to vote for a conservative
because I've got a big program that I
want to get on with delivering so from
my point of view it can't come soon
enough
the timing will be crucial an early
election might reduce the size of the
significant student vote and tactical
campaigning might also emerge if it's
some kind of alliance be an official
alliance or an unofficial alliance I
think people might vote for that I think
there'll be a lot of conservative voters
who are not of the mindset that says
that no deal is better than no exit what
if the Prime Minister plows on
regardless and ignores Parliament it's
beginning to look like Parliament isn't
respected parliamentary sovereignty
hasn't been respected by the government
and it's a wholly unprecedented
situation it really does draw into
question the whole idea of parliamentary
democracy in Britain it's quite scary to
be honest the 2017 election result here
in Canterbury was perhaps the result of
some unique factors the large student
population here the lackluster campaign
fought by the sitting conservative
candidates but just as sources pilgrim
600 years ago came to this city seeking
enlightenment political observers could
do a lot worse than look to this
constituency as an indicator of the
results of the next general election
Paul Brennan al Jazeera Canterbury